It's our shared apprehensions about the
implications of situations for behaviors
that constitute our cultures and it's
those shared maps that bring
predictability to our interpersonal
relationships.
You can only understand that if you
understand what the world is like when
it's not predictable and it's difficult
to understand that for water and people
who live in peaceful times because our
culture is so successful at regulating
our interpersonal behavior and even the
environment for that matter,
but we hardly ever encounter a situation
where anything remotely unpredictable
happens,
so you can't tell what it's like to be
faced with something that's
unpredictable,
so you don't know what it's like when
you're in an environment where it
doesn't rain because you're part of a
successful community in your
extraordinarily well protected it.
You're like,
you're like a a boy that lives inside
the castle.
You can't see over the wall,
doesn't even know that they're there.
There's all sorts of terrible things
outside the castle,
but everything inside is peaceful and
that's the world.
The boy has no idea what he would be
like if we went outside into the real
world where things were actually a
predictable because he's only had a
chance to observe his behavior under
stable conditions.
Wherever that is predictable and
acceptable.
It's even worse now in a sentence.
It's better the way to.
I mean it is peaceful now anyways.
I mean even compared to 15 years ago,
there's much less ideological dispute in
the world about how the conduct is fair
is then there was staying in the mid
seventies when people are more or less.
I mean I know there's exceptions to
this,
but people the world over half,
more or less accepted in this desk,
for example,
for a market economy,
there aren't very many ideologies that
appear attractive even in the
imagination in contrast to to Western
style democracies and I mean that's a
pretty recent occurrence and it's
unlikely to last for any great length of
time I think,
but it is peaceful now that the fact
that that piece makes it even more
difficult for us to either to understand
ourselves or to be sufficiently
motivated.
I'm just kind of just also because when
things are going really well and
everything's predictable,
then you presume that you know what
you're doing.
In fact,
that's the basis on which you base your
judgments about whether you know what
you're doing.
If you perform a procedure and what you
predicted it occurs.
You're right.
That doesn't mean you know everything,
but as far as you're concerned,
that's sufficient.